America's worst mayor wants you to think
she's doing a great job no we're not
talking about her karaoke skills
Chicago's Lori Lightfoot thinks she
deserves another shot at running the
windy city and boasting about her
handling of crime
you wouldn't know it by watching the
news or listening to the haters but on
crime mere lightfoot's got a plan she's
putting more police on the streets and
getting more guns off him when it comes
to new strategies new technology
lightfoot's invested more than any mayor
those are facts speaking of facts here's
a few murders are nearly 40 percent
higher than in 2019 when Lightfoot first
took office and lightfoot's so desperate
to get reelected it looks like she's
bribing children to boost her campaign
Chicago Public School Inspector General
has reportedly opened an investigation
into emails from her campaign asking
teachers to encourage students to
volunteer in exchange for school credit
I mean if I'm getting school credit I
campaign for anybody Greg yeah that is
true that it's a wedding I think of this
you know if you guys could Supply me
with talking points students and that
would be extra credit right wouldn't
that make sense look
imagine she went after gangs the way she
went after like that limo company you
know when she remember she left that
yellow for you she is she is I think the
only mayor of the of a city that is
completely overrun by cartels I mean
they run that City she's not fighting
crime she's fighting for power other
people suffering only crosses her radar
once it poses a political a political
threat and it does show a difference
between Democrats and Republicans
Republicans tend to confront their
problem children be it Santos or
somebody else the Dems just elect them
you know to be a historical first he's a
historical first yeah she's the first
mayor to be under the thumb of cartels
she's the worst mayor in America the
worst mayor Chicago's ever had she looks
like she hasn't slept since 1983. she
dresses like she pantsed the Salvation
Army bell ringer why don't the Democrats
call her out on her record why don't
they say anything it's because they're
cowards and two she's protected by her
diversity Shield right a black lesbian
left Winger so she's like I mean they're
willing pants the salvation exactly so
they're willing to let the city just be
run into the ground a 40 increase in
Murder no white guy could get away with
that that's a bad track record to run on
is anybody running against mayor
Lightfoot I say what I one of the things
I wrote down in the break as we're going
to this is that I just sadly I think
nothing is going to change you're right
like you think about what happened in
Philadelphia when they had a recall
opportunity for to recall that guy
krasner and that he just got reelected
uh the same thing happened out in
California with uh Whatchamacallit there
I can't even think of his name
uh no the Georgia attorney Gusco yeah
that guy a bunch of recalls out in
California I love it the thing is you
know when she says it's the biggest she
wants to invest more than any mayor
that's like when Biden says that there's
it's the biggest drop in gas prices in
history but that's only because it went
up so much under your watch that doesn't
make sense and then yesterday we found
out that young adult males from zip
codes with the most violence in Chicago
and Phil had a notably higher risk of
firearm related death than U.S military
personnel that served in all the years
in Iraq and Afghanistan incredible
that's the ad that I would run there you
got to go to war to be safe that is
crazy Geraldo how how dangerous is
Chicago you've been there I was uh Eric
and I went uh built a trip in to Chicago
around a wedding there in December and
Chicago's Always Been A Tale of Two
Cities South Side North Side uh South
Side the overwhelmingly black and poor
half of the of the city is where most of
the gang violence is happening uh
Chicago is on track now to have over 70
or had over 700 murders and led the
nation by far in murders last year so
she runs on a very tenuous record and
the problem from her point of view
politically is that now that fear of
crime that that absolute Terror has
people on the north side of town the
more affluent side of town getting
private police forces security guards so
it's they're the whole tempo of life in
the windy city has been undermined now
will she be re-elected what do I think
of the idea using kids it's a brilliant
idea to use kids you know it's a scam uh
you it's it's there's an inherent
dishonesty to it and yet you could paint
it as a what a great program get the
kids involved in politics municipal
government and so forth but I I think
Chicago's in a terrible place but I
think that Greg is right I think she
will be re-elected and I I think there's
nothing that you can do about it and it
should only make our shoes and our
phones
freedom to find a shoe company to make a
shoes that wasn't using slave labor or
child labor said it took him six months
to find a company to manufacture his
Footwear
um but I have I have a real problem with
this I mean first of all if this were a
Republican or a Libertarian candidate
for mayor who went to the teachers
unions and said hey tell your kids they
get extra credit for working on my
campaign they would have said oh hell no
and they kind of are they're ratting her
out because to regretted the one thing
that Lori Lightfoot did right was she
stood up to the Chicago teachers unions
when they wanted to keep the schools
closed and she said no absolutely not
keep them up that's the one thing that
she did was pretty good little thing no
and but this this child labor violation
is absolutely disgusting you know why
they're doing it because grades have
tanked so much in the hardest hit
schools in Chicago because of the
pandemic that they have to do whatever
they can to give them credit to boost
their gpas so they have a snow
snowball's chance and Hell of getting
into colleges so there's going to be
middle schoolers with a little placard
that says go Laurie freezing on the
south side of Chicago for school credit
but you know what they make a
bulletproof the kids are going to be out
there you got to keep them safe if one
kid gets hurt out there campaigning for
her it's going to be trouble lights out
she's going to have to answer to me I
went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now